the biden administration apparently not
very concerned with surging gas prices
gas guzzling private jet owner and
climate czar john kerry is once again
pushing climate alarmism
unabated fossil fuel is allowed to grow
in these next years in a significant way
as it appears
poised to do
that is a deep
unbelievably costly challenge for the
world
all right dana is climate change a deep
challenge for the world
it's a challenge it is there's a lot of
challenges like so many as we were
talking about the to-do list the other
day
i think that you know having somebody
that flies around on a private jet
talking about reducing greenhouse gas
emissions is maybe not the best
messenger and
i understand that it's a problem i also
understand that you can't change the
laws of physics it's i think it's
wonderful to have innovation and to
encourage people to try to do things
there's some really interesting things
going on with fusion for example but
they're taking one issue and going to
create another one which is that the
fossil fuels and greenhouse gas
emissions problem that needs to be dealt
with okay but now pushing so quickly to
have electric vehicles which is and also
doing all the subsidies so that rich
people can have electric vehicles like a
tesla for example um
the rare earths that are needed in order
to make that happen all those minerals
you think you're going to have climate
problems you're going to have
environmental problems from geopolitical
problems that come from that as well why
don't they see that stuff joey i see you
laughing why don't they anticipate that
this is a divisive issue really that's
what it comes down to you got to be on
one side or the other what i want to
know is how many of the keystone
pipeline workers are have learned to
code yeah how many of them have been
re-jobbed you know like we re-home a pet
how many how many of them are making a
hundred thousand dollars a year in a
green energy job now probably not many
because they still come on here
pretty pissed off about how things went
down with their job and taking their
livelihood away from them you cannot be
the party that touts being the party of
the downtrodden american who's had you
know a terrible go at it and be the ones
downtrodding them be the ones pulling
the rug out from under them listen i'm a
conservationist but the line between
environmentalism and climate change the
religion of climate change that's a
broader gulf than any of us can reach
those are two very different things
there's a difference between
understanding the need to conserve our
resources and trying to shove this down
our throats to the point that i mean
clay travis was on tv this morning
talking about he watched someone put
one gallon of fuel in their car for four
dollars and 59 cents yeah because that's
all they could afford yeah and you want
to talk about republican sweeping house
not only are you pushing voters towards
republicans you're pushing americans
away from even believing in climate
change or wanting to support it that's
what's so ironic and dumbfounding about
this
you know one of the things that jen
sackey says harold is that we're not
holding back any drilling and yet
apparently the climate advisor
also says that biden is committed to
opposing any additional drilling do they
even know what their position is as it
relates to drilling other than that
they're appealing to the left
we should be drilling uh we should be
building nuclear we should be
and we should be um
we should be fracking
the reality is climate change is real uh
but to joey's point we have to be
thoughtful and serious about how we make
that transition uh the war in ukraine
obviously has made this a far more far
more relevant and poignant conversation
but for the life of me
this this conversation this moment in
need screams for just some sanity your
point you don't have to be this way or
that way on this we could both say that
that you're conservationists and we want
uh climate change the realities of it
for us to address we want electric cars
and to build batteries one thing we
should realize china's building all the
batteries and we're going to that's ten
years from now we're going to have this
issue so we can't just abandon it all
together but democrats
i listened to my friend fred smith last
night on brett bear's show he said that
president obama said to him at one time
in the white house that my poll numbers
are correlate directly to oil prices i
need not say much more if we find
ourselves in a bind come november we
could really be in a bond if we don't
look as if we're trying to address this
issue so i imagine greg that you agree
that the climate change is not the
existential threat that they say it is i
think it it is a challenge that we will
be facing but a lot of the solutions
that are coming from the left are
unreliable whether it's solar panels or
windmills i mean look at cnn plus
how much money they invested in wind
power by hiring chris wallace
so anyway i'm gonna defend uh
uh the president uh while we while we're
talking about this he just uh i guess
funded a six billion dollar effort to
save distressed nuclear
power plants to secure our energy supply
so that's a that's a great thing which i
think you know when you talk about
having
republicans and democrats the mom and
the dad in the same room that's what you
get you get a solution where like both
can agree like nuclear power is
essentially going to be our future we're
just got to admit it at a certain point
but they're going to start building him
rolls-royce is going to be building
these smaller uh plants and they're
clean uh and uh we're all going to live
with unicorns in clouds okay there you
have it all right yes ahead mike tyson
punches out a passenger the shocking
video and more coming up in the fastest
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else